My name is Tia Kratter, I've been at Pixar 16 years,...
...and I have quit every year for the past 11 years.
Tia Kratter: she's one of the most amazing, talented artists here.
She's worked on just about every film.
I grew up in a family of practical jokesters.
It's April 1st, 1998; something like that.
So I e-mailed the entire company and said I'm leaving Pixar.
Goodbye.
And I got about 20 to 30 people that bit.
A couple of women in the production office...
...actually went out and ordered this beautiful little chocolate cake.
The benefits were so good that I just thought, "I have to do this every year."
I just fell for it.
She said a nice goodbye, but it was April 1st that she sent the mail...
...and halfway through the mail you realize, she's not quitting...
...because she's usually in the mail, off to do...
...some super bizarre thing like art direct "Tron 2."
I've quit to go airbrush monster trucks.
I've quit because I went to work in a wax museum,...
...and one year, I had an affair.
There's just enough truth in her e-mail that if you didn't know her, you would buy it...
...and it always causes a stir.
Steve Jobs believed my letter on three separate occasions.
Fact.
We finally got Tia back, she sent a mail; it was obviously April Fools' Day.
It must have been on a Friday or something; she wasn't there.
So what we did is we had her whole office packed up.
We even changed the door.
She came back; the key didn't work.
Then when she finally got it open and went in,...
...and all her stuff was literally boxed up, floor to ceiling.
But it didn't stop.
She quit again this year.
It is so much fun.